minions or monsters the new amazon
series the rings of power portrays orcs
in a much different light than the
iconic film trilogy keep watching to
find out how faithful to the original
text they really are when you sit down
to watch a live action version of a jrr
tolkien story it's virtually guaranteed
that you'll see folks like hobbits elves
and dwarves over the course of the
adventure likewise at one point or
another there's going to be orcs these
twisted brutal creatures oppose the
protagonists of the lord of the rings on
multiple occasions and make up the bulk
of saurons and saruman's armies in
climactic battles peter jackson's a
hobbit film trilogy even features
prominent orc lords azorg and bolg the
orcs in the various movies are imposing
and fearsome looking and they hiss grunt
and raw exactly like you'd assume
however in the grand scheme of things
the live-action or groups we've seen so
far are essentially just factions that
happen to oppose the heroes because they
serve the villain and it's their literal
job description to do so sure as boromir
fatally finds out in the lord of the
rings fellowship of the ring
particularly strong orcs at the aurochi
have been known to achieve major
victories still by and large orcs serve
the same purpose as stormtroopers do in
star wars movies their unsympathetic
cannon fudder for the heroes to mow down
by the dozen that is until amazon prime
videos critically acclaimed the lord of
the rings the rings of power turned up
the series doesn't take long to
establish orcs as a true terror and in
doing so the show finally makes them as
horrifying as tolkien intended every
tolkien-themed live-action project has
managed to portray orcs as creepy
creatures however the rings of power
episode 2 outer right turns them into
horror movie villains by leaning hard on
their digging abilities which tolkien
has noted rival the dwarves themselves
these orcs don't just look like slasher
movie monsters either they also play the
part
they provide copious jump scares they
stalk terrified hiding people and as
brown win and theo find out first hand
they're extremely hard to kill when
you're not a powerful hero armed with
rare and luxurious weaponry even
well-equipped and trained elven warrior
orondia gets a scare of his lifetime as
he flees the terrifying enemies and then
just when he least expects it several
clawed hands emerge from the darkness
and grab him from behind it's horrifying
stuff and a very good take on tolkien's
orcs out of all of the different beings
in the lord of the rings they might just
be the most twisted but there's still
more or less cannon fodder in the movies
which is far from the unyielding
monsters tolkien wrote the mass the
author wrote about orcs and their
creator sauron's old boss malcolm aka
morgoth in the fall of gondolin their
hearts were of granite and their bodies
deformed foul their faces which smiled
not but their laugh for that of the
clash of metal and to nothing were they
more feign than to aid in the basis of
the purposes of melco now which
portrayal fits that description better
the unruly minions of the movies or the
ruthless stalking beasts in the rings of
power episode 2. according to an idn
article about the rings of powers or
game the feral and terrifying version of
orcs we see in the show is a very
premeditated approach
executive producer lindsay webber said
we spent a lot of time talking about
what it would mean to be an orc in the
second age it felt appropriate that
their look would be different part of a
wilder more raw second age middle earth
closer to where the first stage ends as
we meet them they're not yet organized
into armies they're a little more
scattered and they've been scavenging
weber also teased that the show will
feature all sorts of different orcs
including female ones interestingly the
unnerving effect of the show's orcs are
so strong that even the actors were
thrown off by them as lloyd owen who
plays noteboard numenorean elendil in
the show told metro the orcs
legitimately creeped him out on set the
actor said you get a visceral reaction
to it which is rejection ultimately i
don't want to be around that based on
what we've seen so far it's difficult to
imagine anyone wanting to be around the
show's orcs for any amount of time but
from the looks of it the people of
middle earth might not have any other
option
[Music]
you